if you're 47 years old and you think
you're finished you need to rethink
everything shit's happening and you need
to take advantage of your thing and the
fact that most of you are not taking
advantage of this opportunity because of
the insecurities that your [__] up
parents or your neighborhood gave to you
breaks my [__] heart I am so
frustrated by watching all the teenagers
and 20 year olds take full advantage of
this opportunity because they don't know
any better and for the 40 and 50 and 60
year olds closing their mind without
realizing that they're going to live for
the next 40 years and this [__] land
grab is for you too and good news hold
[__] you have experience
thank you